[Music]
good morning good morning I came here
yesterday and I asked everyone to be
open and honest and the first time I
heard any honesty last night was with
your mother not easy that is it I don't
condone your behavior my behavior was
was I just felt like you're letting the
language that you used wasn't that of an
English gentleman like I would expect
deeply sorry about that what what
language did I use a lot of f-words and
I don't appreciate you using that
language with my angel of a mother and
my sister so just stop you there cuz you
ever exaggerating a little bit because
I'm not gonna give you brownie points
standing in front of your mother telling
me how upset you are when you're
laughing digging in with me at the same
time you see as it is if you have to
call it as it is I like the fact you're
standing up so it takes me to swear for
you to step up an act like a man please
you don't know [ __ ] did you just curse
that's disgusting behavior young man if
you want to have a little chat with me
later together one on one I'd love that
but stop being a hypocrite
you've just sworn in front of your
mother that was a mistake and I
apologize mom the hours you turn in four
o'clock in the afternoon I don't know
how you can call that a full day's work
Gina was frustrated the fact you don't
commit stuff get no direction and you
walk around shaking cocktails but I
don't need to prove to you Milo now ask
you to prove it to me your father put
you in charge at the restaurant so the
big question is what was your son Zach
doing here my view was he was gonna come
help me run the restaurant he's not even
getting feedback or talking to Gina or
even just asking service to not chew gum
yes it concerns me a great deal okay
shall we move on I've got something
really important to tell you please yes
it's something you're not familiar with
it's called feedback
what's here I found some time this
morning just travelling around driving
thinking contemplating and popping in to
local places fly fishermen locals houses
cabins you name it I went there the sad
news is they didn't wanna come and sort
of tell you to your face because it's a
small community but I've got the
feedback my daughter had a wedding
reception held at the lodge we would go
back and celebrate but over the years
things have gone downhill Dave makes us
very very unwelcome and he has pushed
the town away it doesn't feel like they
want us there
the owners seriously well needs help
he's a total horsies but he has no idea
how to handle employees or his customers
there was a time the community rallied
round to help them but he showed no
appreciation so didn't last very long
after time he was a jackass again
couldn't care less too bad so much
potential there maybe they don't care I
don't know why everybody thinks I'm a
horse's ass I guess I am huh I try to be
friendly to people and treat them just
like I've treated you have I come across
cold and arrogant you come across
controlling and you come across
assertive yeah we need to get them on
our side whether we like it or not their
last comment to me was that if you are
prepared to change and commit to change
than they words walk through those doors